a California mother is suing a charter
school alleging a bullying incident left
her son with severe brain damage the
woman says school officials did nothing
to stop it Nikki Batiste is here with
this difficult story Nikki the
allegations here are heroin what
happened exactly well Tony this is a
terrible story that every parent dreads
their child bullied at school now one
California mother is taking legal action
to bring about change she spoke with our
Los Angeles affiliate KCBS and didn't
want to show her face or name to protect
her son's identity she says she wants
accountability
that child that I dropped off at at 7 30
that morning he is not the same anymore
this mother says school officials at
Animo West Side Charter Middle School in
Los Angeles didn't do enough to protect
her son from a school bully that hurts
because I that's all I have could have
been prevented only if someone cared it
was January of 2018 School surveillance
cameras show a small boy getting off the
bus when he's approached by a much
larger boy who punches him and allegedly
puts him in a Chokehold at one point a
staff member walks by but doesn't
intervene according to the lawsuit the
boy allegedly lost Consciousness twice
he has eventually helped inside where
staff members realize what's going on
bringing him to the main office and
laying him down on the floor while they
call his mother
when she finally arrived she says no one
had called 9-1-1 a son is literally
laying there still in the middle of the
office floor completely black and blue
Ben Marcellus is the attorney
representing the mother and her son the
school district has seen the video the
fact that they can watch that video and
not so much offer an apology
is really really really disgusting
according to the complaint the boy
suffered permanent Brain and Spine
damage as well as post-traumatic sleep
disorder in a statement the organization
Green Dot which runs the charter school
writes we take seriously the safety of
all of our students and quickly address
bullying of any kind on our campuses we
promptly and thoroughly investigate any
complaint and take appropriate
corrective action the boy's mother says
she wants an apology and can't believe
the bully was never expelled I think
across the board there should be
discipline you know and I think that
that can include termination
the lawsuit is asking for unspecified
damages and the mother in her interview
says she's going after the school not
the boy the bully was actually at her
son's birthday party a few weeks before
she spoke to his mother his brother had
recently passed away he'd been having
anger issues so she really feels that
the school should have stepped in here
the school or they're about eight
bystanders there you know other kids
should know you can step in you don't
have to stand there and watch it the
mother sounded remarkably calm to me I
would be outraged I mean disgusting is
the right word and sickening it's just
it's very tough and the kid there's
there's such a big difference between
the size of the two and the fact I'm so
angry too with the staff member that
kept walking I'm very impressed by the
mother that has sympathy for the bully
of yeah you wonder never mind expelled
you wonder if the kid should be arrested
yes yes I mean she has incredible Grace
but you know everyone talk to your kids
about bullying step in if you see
something don't be a bison right now
he's still in school though the bully is
still in the school as far as we know
yes wow what's wrong on so many levels
thank you Nikki